a big announcement this morning ces will
return
in person at the las vegas convention
center this upcoming january it was all
virtual this year of course
bianca holman is there live now with
details and the outlook on conventions
for
2022 hi bianca well ces the consumer
electronics show is the biggest
convention held here in las vegas and
of course there were plans for it to be
here in the new expansion part of the
convention center but instead was held
virtually this year
as far as next year though it's going to
be in person january 5th
through the 8th ces tweeted the
announcement
see you in january and share the dates
of the convention
not only is this convention huge for las
vegas but it's also one of the largest
trade shows in the country
and one of the world's most influential
tech events lori nelson craft with lvcva
says the new expansion is ideal for the
20 conventions confirmed for the
remainder of this year
and now ces in 2022
the overall destination has 14 million
square feet
of event and meeting space this is a
beautiful contemporary space
you'll notice a lot of natural light we
have
an outdoor terrace with views of the
strip that will allow you to host events
upwards of 2000 people
and we just think it's going to be a
game changer in the meeting and event
industry
and it makes las vegas convention center
the
second largest convention center in the
united states
in past years there are more than 200
thousand people that came to las vegas
and of course those folks bring an
estimated 200 million dollars to our
economy
the return of this convention is a
significant milestone and major
announcement for the valley
now back out here you can expect this
area of course in front of the new
convention portion to be busy
in june because there's going to be the
world of concrete and that is going to
happen
june 8th through the 10th bianca holman
8 news now